it's quite fun being unique filming a
harry potter movie might sound like a
magical experience for a young actor
and it was but it was also a huge
challenge after the huge success of the
first film the cast and crew came back
for the chamber of secrets
raring to go but when it came to
balancing schoolwork
tons of cgi a cast of hundreds and
everything else filming the second harry
potter movie was no easy feat
we're taking a look at some of the most
amazing behind-the-scenes moments from
the chamber of secrets
you might think that the young actors
and hard-working crew would have been
given a break between filming the first
harry potter film and the chamber of
secrets
but nope they started shooting the
second movie only two days after the
first premiered
and coming back to work was like getting
a big family back together
after getting all of the introductions
out of the way in the first movie
the second time around allowed them to
not only make the chamber of secrets
more funny
but also way darker and far more
action-packed
the director chris columbus was so
excited to be able to direct more of the
action
and daniel radcliffe was definitely on
board when it came to making the
audience laugh
while they mostly stuck to the script a
few key lines from the chamber of
secrets were actually
improvised first the hilarious moment
when malfoy turns to goyle
or harry disguised as goyle and says
what the naked breed
was made up by tom felton because he
forgot his line
and secondly when jason isaacs says the
potter will
always be around to save the day
he came up with it on the spot luckily
daniel radcliffe was right there with
him as his response
don't worry i will be
was totally off the top of his head
according to daniel
all of the flying car sequences took
around a month to film which meant that
he and rupert were trapped together in a
tiny car for four weeks
luckily he thought rupert was hilarious
and the two kept each other laughing
even after flying right into the
whomping willow
oh yeah that was really fun it's clear
that they had
a great time because dan said those were
some of the best filming days i think
and they had only just begun rupert and
daniel weren't the only ones who became
fast friends
because it turns out that even though
they might be rivals on screen
dan and tom felton who plays malfoy
actually get along
really well but we're not really enemies
we love each other really
they had a lot of fun filming their
quidditch scenes
spending hours hanging from the ceiling
in front of a giant blue screen
joking around between takes after the
huge success of the first movie
they were able to spend a little less
time worrying and a lot more time having
fun
on the set of the chamber of secrets
even doing things that seemed like
the complete opposite of a good time for
example the scene where ron has to throw
up a bunch of giant slugs might be a
nightmare to most of us
but for rupert it was a whole other
story but it tasted quite nice actually
they even let him choose the flavor
three new big characters were introduced
in the second movie
lucius malfoy gilderoy lockhart and of
course
dobby but this movie was made before the
days of motion capture
and super realistic cgi so acting
opposite dobby was
actually a big challenge for daniel
radcliffe challenging on the part of the
visual effects team
and challenging on the part of dan
raglev dobby wouldn't be created until
after the movie was filmed so he spent
the entire time
acting opposite an orange ball nowadays
they might shoot the entirety of
hogwarts on a green screen but
back then they did almost all of it for
real
one of the most complicated tasks was
building dumbledore's office which took
over 250 people to do
for just that one room along with
building the space
they had to commission a handful of
different artists to paint
all of the portraits and paintings that
hang on his walls
playing quidditch might look like an
amazing amount of fun
but it turns out it took quite a bit of
getting used to
according to daniel radcliffe in the
first movie it was actually
really painful to spend so long up there
sitting on a tiny broomstick suspended
by wires
but luckily by the time the chamber of
secrets came around they had figured out
a way for it to be
a lot less painful and way more fun
by rigging in more comfortable seats and
foot rests and using wires to keep their
weight off of the broom
according to chris columbus the main
trio quickly went from actors with no
experience to seasoned professionals
from the first movie to the second
i've developed as a person so much
everybody on set has everything got a
little easier and started to flow more
the second time around
and what once took 10 to 15 takes to
nail down only took
three or four on the chamber of secrets
even though they may have been becoming
best friends
that didn't mean that daniel emma and
rupert were free from teasing each other
every now and again
in fact they did it all the time why are
you so determined to embarrass
me because they were all growing at
different rates they were all racing to
keep up with one another
especially emma who was the only girl in
the group but don't worry
rupert and daniel didn't gang up on her
and she could totally hold her own
i am total video or i will make myself
the young actors were really excited to
see their characters grow
and change from where they were in the
first year at hogwarts to the second
daniel radcliffe was intent on making
harry more grounded the second time
around
in the first movie he was more just
reacting to things around him
and in the second he really started to
take charge of his world
emma watson said that hermione
definitely relaxed a bit for the second
film
hermione definitely becomes more sort of
easy going ron stepped into the big
brother role with ginny now enrolled at
hogwarts
and also with his new owl who as rupert
grint put it is
he's really really stupid and clumsy
one thing that everyone in the cast and
crew could agree upon is that chris
columbus was the absolute best director
for the job
not only was he a great leader he also
knew exactly how to talk to the young
actors and get the best work out of them
he manages to get the whole set
completely psyched up
while some directors sit in another room
looking at the monitor and never
speaking to the cast
chris did exactly the opposite and was
super hands on the
entire time having already been working
together as a giant family for over a
year on the chamber of secrets
the actors finally started to feel like
they could step out of their comfort
zones a little bit
one thing that the success of the first
film enabled us to do is to
sit back and be a little more relaxed
for dan he was so shy during the first
movie that he would never offer his
opinion about anything other than a
funny prank or two
but when it came to the second one he
was a lot more comfortable and started
sharing his ideas and thoughts with the
director
and really getting into the work in the
second
i kind of have a bit more confidence
with putting ideas forward
according to emma watson one of the
biggest challenges of being a young
actor on a giant hollywood set
is trying to fit everything in because
while most kids their age would be in
school full time
all of the school-age harry potter
actors had to be tutored on set
during the day while also filming the
movie for up to 12 hours a day
they would run from the set to the
tutoring trailer for a 15 minute lesson
back to hair and makeup and on set again
all day long
after all this it seems like making the
chamber of secrets was an
amazing experience for everyone involved
and we're sure that
none of the crew would trade it even for
a second
we know that at 12 we would have so
rather been making a magical movie than
going to math class
how about you thanks for watching
bye